at least four people have been killed in
an attack on a hotel in the Somali
Capital Market issue the armed grouper
shabab has claimed responsibility gunman
stormed the Villa Rose Hotel which is
close to the presidential Palace and is
regularly used by government officials
several people have been rescued
somalia's minister of State for
environment and climate change Adam Al
hirsi joins me now on the phone from
Mogadishu he was at the hotel at the
time of the attack so good to have you
with us have government forces now taken
control of the hotel or is the battle
still ongoing
the cleanup is continuing the security
forces have been patterning them since
the attack happened and we were rescued
to a safer place from the background of
the hotel and now it is not over yet but
we are being advised that the bulk of
operations have ended
well you were at the hotel at the time
of the tech can you describe to us how
it unfolded
it was after we have finished the disha
a congregation prayers he's been in
congregation Parish in the mosque in
brotal and shorted after 7 30 p.m uh
this massive deafening explosion
happened towards the grade of the hotel
and then bullets started to rain from
all darsh uh from the God is similar by
our own goddess and from the uh
terrorists of food so we mean very
quickly we have been told uh to head to
the back door we gathered in a in an
area a graveyard nearby the hotel then
we have been led to say that's that's in
the back door of the hotel
and do you have an update on the number
of casualties
the the uh there are people that were
evacuated to hospitals and there are
people that died on this spot we have
been advised that uh six to eight people
have been spotted that in the uh are in
and around the the hotel the location of
the uh the terrorist attack and people
might have died in the hospitals or
might not
right the hotel was frequented obviously
by government officials such as yourself
was there a security failure for this
group of assailants to be able to get
into such a sensitive place and such
sensitive part of Margaret issue
of course there was a failure if there
was no failure terrorists would not
preach the the Gate of the hotel that we
were meeting in but remember we are in a
war a raging a war that guns are blazing
the terrorists kingdoms are running for
their lives in the remote villages in
Somalia in and isabeli and other parts
of the country so this uh a manifest is
that they are throwing their last kicks
and using their last tricks in the books
in their death Pros
right the government offensively the
strategy of all-out War has cleared a
shabab from some areas of Somalia but
the UN says for example when it comes to
civilian casualties they have risen this
year by 30 and in fact they're at their
highest level since 2017
is the government winning the security
battle the battle to make life more
secure for citizens
well of course there is there is a pain
in the interim and we have decided to
finish this
for all and there will be a casualties
similar casualties and they want to
increase the casualties of civilians so
that we met up the war and we're not
going to let up the War uh I think this
is uh the quiet time to finish this the
Somali communities all of them Rises up
against this terrorist group who are
living in the place that they were
extorting people training people using
misusing their scripts making Islam look
back so basically this is that this is
the time to finish them off
yes as I said there will be pain but in
the interim but it is not a pain that
will endure that will wait for our
children and our grandchildren we are
determined to finish this and we will
finish it inshaallah
okay thank you so much for your um for
your time